hey welcome back everybody to LED live
today we've got an exciting topic again
for you what are you gonna do if you're
in search for the wrong light find out
on this episode of LED live welcome back
everybody we are very excited to have
you on Mike Shreve you know you are
literally putting your finger on a pulse
that we get a lot of questions on a lot
of people want to know information on
the new age topic they seem to be some
of the more watched videos that we've
we've produced so I'm excited to hear
your testimony I'm happy to be here how
you got involved in this and many of you
guys have maybe seen our other LED that
we had Jessica Smith on Mike was a
friend of Jessica Smith and helped her
actually I run the publishing company
that published her book awesome it's a
deeper revelation books right up the
road 30 months awesome so he's almost
our neighbor so glad to have you on the
show today we're really excited to get
into this topic but first we want to
thank our patreon donors thank you guys
so much for keeping our lights on you
know this has been a really neat year
and we've had a lot of support from you
guys so thank you so much for those of
you who are also new to this channel
don't forget to subscribe if you like
what you see hit that like button and
these are meant to be shared with your
friends and so you know if you know
somebody who's either struggling with
this topic maybe looking into the New
Age or something that's real easy to
send them a link and say hey we've got a
video for you to watch you know here's a
guy that was involved in in teaching
Kundalini if I'm right right when
Delaney yoga Kundalini Yoga so you guys
aren't gonna want to miss this testimony
but we also have a lot of videos DVDs
that we make on various different
projects this one would be very similar
to the Dragon revealed where we followed
around a guy who spent 25 years in the
martial arts world and real
got caught up in the same sort of thing
as well so you might want to check those
out
you can rent them on Vimeo or you can
get them on our website but without
further ado Mike I would love to ya hear
a little bit of on how you got involved
in a teaching I mean Kundalini is kind
of a crazy thing to get involved in
first off it's probably the most intense
type of yoga there are dozens of
different expressions of yoga and
Kundalini Yoga is supposed to be an
amalgamation of all of them from hatha
yoga which is the fundamental kind of
yoga that deals with asanas which are
physical exercises and pranayama which
are breathing exercises people think
those are harmless and unspiritual but
they are the third and fourth step of
eight steps that are supposed to lead
you to Samadhi which is Hindu term for
an enlightened state and so that's the
reason I got into yoga of course it's
been a while back it's been back in 1970
I was a college student I was a rock
musician I had a near-death experience
that shook me up I felt my soul leaving
my body and going out into this dark
throbbing void and it was a tunnel and I
was speeding up transitioning into
another world and I had no idea what was
on the other side and I realized my
self-centered life and my focus on
material things was completely worthless
Wow when you face death I mean it
doesn't matter anymore so I came back
from that experience but I was a changed
person in a good way interesting because
it put me on a journey right and it was
such a consuming thing in my heart I
couldn't handle just pursuing a career
through a college degree anymore and so
I dropped out of school not that I
advocate people do that but I dropped
out of Florida State University because
I met an Indian guru named yogi Basha
and he taught this type of yoga called
Kundalini Yoga I loved the idea of a
totally disciplined life from 3:30 in
the morning till 5:00
thirty in the afternoon we were in very
regimented disciplines from meditation
to chanting mantras to reading the
bhagavad-gita to doing physical yoga
exercise all focused on one goal and
that was the awakening of this
mysterious thing called the Kundalini so
that I could come into what they termed
God conscious and enlightenment however
and maybe we'll go into this more later
on when you say God consciousness that
sounds like a wonderful thing right to
be consciously aware of God what could
be wrong with that
truth often lies just in parallel with
the error right absolutely and deception
veils the truth in acceptable terms and
what people don't realize is that within
the framework of Eastern religions and
New Age spirituality God consciousness
means a conscious awareness that you are
God you have God inside of you which
brings us all to the Garden of Eden not
just God inside of you but you are gone
that God the Godhead is manifesting
itself interesting and I did say itself
on purpose because in Hinduism the
ultimate reality is Brahman right which
is an impersonal cosmic force just you
don't pray to Brahman Obama's not going
to answer but you awaken this major
Virginia until you realize that upman
your individual soul is actually Brahman
and there's no duality there that's all
been in an illusion and that's that's
the framework of what most Hindus
believe not all Hindus but most Hindus
believe that so I dove in I got into it
completely month after month after month
day after day I was involved in
meditation involved in yoga and and it
was a grand departure from my youth
in fact I sent your picture of me as a
young strong with the light around him
yeah that's not a halo ba yeah but
that's me as an altar boy in the
Catholic Church
I only met good priests and good nuns
there there were a few nuns in grade
school that were pretty fierce I don't
blame them to be honest but I got a lot
of good character principles from them
and father Biddle he's pictured there
with me he was just a gracious gentle
person that taught good character and
taught a historical Christ but he never
told me how to have a personal
relationship with God he was a good man
but he never told me how to go beyond
good to God and really haven't you had a
beginning with religion I mean you you
were aware that there's a God out there
we'll see a lot of people get into New
Age go through the same steps they're
part of a nominal religion that
professes faith in a historical Christ I
put it this way that the professing
church is about 2.5 billion people in
the world that professed faith in
Christianity in the Bible in the Lord
Jesus Christ death burial resurrection
and ascension but then there's a core
group there's a nucleus of people that I
call the possessing church people and
it's trans denominational people that
possess a genuine relationship with the
Lord Jesus Christ which makes all the
difference
that's what Jesus call that's what Jesus
called being born again and I guess I
should get into the transitional points
where I was born again because that made
all the difference in my life
right and it's definitely not the same
as Nirvana right or Christ consciousness
or self-awareness or all these other
very high-flying terms that sound very
attractive but you believed in those
things right I mean if you're teaching
them one is actually different a lot of
people think it's all packaged together
right but Nirvana is from Buddhism and
the word Nirvana comes from a root that
means blowing out like the blowing out
of a candle and it actually means
cessation of personal existence where
you see
be as an individual because Buddhism
does not teach that you have a soul
in Hinduism you have the soul in
Buddhism you just cease to exist
add death and Nirvana is a realization
of the fact that everything is
impermanent and there it has no lasting
existence and you're supposed to resign
yourself over to that and accept it and
it brings greater peace in your life
because you're not clean to material
things anymore you realize this all
transitory so Buddhism is a different
kind of approach than new-age although
most New Agers just package it all the
gate kind of gets washed out not just
the Christian faith right I quoted Jesus
all the time and I read the Aquarian
gospel which is the Gospel where Jesus
teaches new age principles of course I
believe it is interesting absolutely
it's not jamanakai but I was very quick
to quote in fact the Guru I studied
under would quote Jesus all the time he
would try to prove the existence of the
chakras and the third eye by quoting
where Jesus said let your eye be single
right and if your eye is single your
whole body will be full of light whoa
yeah well hidden mystery he's talking
about the third eye no he wasn't
yeah because you pull that out of
context yeah when you put it back in
context he was talking about materialism
versus spirituality he was talking about
people that get so focused on money and
Mammon that they lose their way in life
and when he said let your eye be single
he was talking about being focused on
spiritual things he wasn't talking about
some esoteric thing that you have to
have the third eye awakened because
there's no such thing
chakras are imaginary but I do believe
people that meditate on the chakras and
and think they have an actual existence
they
they opened a door to demonic
infestation of their lives I know I
became demon-possessed doing yoga
because by the way the word the
Kundalini is inseparably tied in with
the chakras the idea of the chakra
because the Kundalini is supposedly now
I don't believe this now but this is
what I used to teach fifty years ago
back in nineteen seventy I taught it for
universities University of South Florida
University of Tampa Florida Presbyterian
and you believe that and a place called
New College down in Sarasota Florida had
about three or four hundred students who
thought I was their guru and the word
guru means one who brings you out of
darkness into light interesting the
problem was I wasn't in the light yet
it's not just crazy how the devil uses
these these very similar concepts to
Christianity boys lips it like like that
that is the mission of a person that
really believes in God right to bring
people out of darkness into his
marvelous light yeah but yet it's like
they flip it and then they go oh you're
bringing people into the light but it's
like totally bringing them into darkness
and that's why most people think that
all these different religions are
completely compatible and they interface
with each other but they don't not when
you really study them in depth there's
no way just to give a big blatant
example on one extreme you've got
Hinduism that teaches ultimate reality
as an impersonal cosmic force and that
there's 330 million gods and goddesses
that manifest out of that force and or
out of that energy that consciousness
level and so they teach majority of
Hindus teach pantheism which is the idea
that the whole universe is a
manifestation of the Godhead or an
emanation of the Godhead that God had
emanated itself once again is neuter
itself in the form of the universe and
so everything has a divine essence so in
Hinduism everything is God now on the
opposite extreme you've got islam and
islam teaches that one of the worst sins
you can commit is shirk shi RK which is
a tree
divinity to anything or anyone other
than Allah you see and so that's why a
Muslim believes a Christian who believes
Jesus was divine was the Son of God God
manifested in the flesh is totally off
and and blasphemous heretical and
deserving of death and so crazy when the
whole Bible centers around Jesus it's
like pointing to Jesus Jesus is the it's
like the the pinnacle point when when
God says this is the plan of salvation
right here at centers around this
character so yeah but anyway my point
let me make I'll make it real quick is
that you've got Hinduism that says
everything is God you've got Islam that
says nothing is God how can you say both
of those are completely compatible right
it's a different view altogether then in
between you've got Christianity that
offers a unique view of the Godhead that
nobody else offers and that is the
triune nature of God Father Son and Holy
Spirit that these three are one you
don't find that in Zoroastrianism you
don't find that in Jainism or Shinto
only in Christianity
so we pride ourselves when I say we I
say generally as a culture pride
ourselves on our scientific mindset
which which is based on experimentation
observation and then you line up the
criteria and if it doesn't fulfill the
criteria you toss something out and so
we we are very good at discerning or try
to be very good at discerning correct
from incorrect assumptions about
different aspects of nature and life etc
why then do we toss out any kind of
discrimination when it comes to
spiritual matters I think that that's
bigotry and that's and that's unfair to
those that embrace that worldview and
we've got to say your truth is your
truth of much or the most modern truth
is not subjective truth is object
it's the same for everybody that's right
whether we accept or not well I was
taught you were gonna inject something
I'm sorry I just want to back up a
little bit for people you you're because
I think this is a fundamental point in
all of the whole yoga practice what does
the word yoga mean very fundamental and
very important
it means yoke but the symbolic
implication is to be yoked with Brahman
have you ever seen somebody sitting in
the lotus position with their hands like
this people think that's a harmless way
to sit and and just calm your mind but
that's what's called a mudra the mudra
is a symbolic gesture with the hand or
with the body that represents the
spiritual concept the forefinger
represents your individual soul it
called upman in in sanskrit and the
thumb represents brahman the Oversoul
that impersonal lifeforce when you curl
your finger around and touch it like
that it is an invocation you are
invoking Brahman to manifest completely
in your life so that you become God
manifested in the flesh speak I mean we
we've covered this topic a few times and
I'm always shocked when you see like
Christian yoga group doing that no let's
start a Christian beer company says come
to me all you who labor and are
heavy-laden I will give you rest and
after that he says take my yoke upon you
and learn from me I am gentle and lowly
in heart and you will find rest for your
souls my yoke is easy my burden is light
that's an awesome comparison yeah
because because that implies that human
beings to be complete must be yoked with
some room and if you're not yoked to
Christ you're gonna be yoked to a
philosophy or spiritual concept or
something that you're gonna grasp for in
order to find that completion but it's
going to be hard exactly because in
Hinduism you got to go through over a
million
reincarnation before you can get free
from this cycle of rebirths
and that's a lot of pain to face and
unless of course it doesn't happen it
doesn't work that way but his yoke is
easy
it doesn't involve all these complicated
SOT really ideas and rituals and
ceremonies just make him Lord of your
life love God with all your heart love
people Jesus does all the heavy lifting
yeah I like you too by ourselves it's
like you said it's it's hard it's
difficult until you come to Christ life
you know it is interesting that when you
listen to other religions and what
they're asking those people to believe
the mental gymnastics that you have to
do to understand what's going on around
the world but then they look at
Christianity and it's like wow whatever
I can't possibly have been created in
seven literal days you know and it's
like you you you think of like look at
this gymnastics that you have to like
wrap your head around it's wild what
people are willing to accept to believe
when when you literally just get to the
bottom of what the Christian faith is
really describing that God and and and
how man was created and all that it's
like it seems a way easier to believe in
they're like you believe there's an
impersonal force and I was I had a past
life as some vibration and and if I keep
my vibration at this positive level then
I'll okay enter into another vibration I
mean that really seems like more work
than just like wow there's a there's a
war going on in heaven Jesus needed to
come and die for my sin so that I can I
mean that's just seems simple and all of
that is mechanical like chanting the
same words ten thousand times
that's very mechanical that's like
inserting a program on your computer in
person that's supposed to result in the
right kind of output well Jesus even
taught use not vain repetitions like the
heathens great because right now we're
having a conversation mm-hmm and if I
was to sit here and say the same five
word of statement two hundred times how
long would you keep outside
you would exit stage left right and you
guys don't remember exit stage a little
pink guy a little Pink Panther indeed
always but anyway is because you're
intelligent human beings and the way for
us to connect relationally is to express
a flow of thought in a communicable way
from heart to heart from mind to mind
well communication with God is the same
and I tell people that chanting a mantra
is an insult to the intelligence of God
God was just an impersonal force it
would make sense chant 10,000 times and
you can manipulate the force to do what
you wanted to do right it's all
mechanical but if God is a personal God
which he is then that's not going to get
you to the first base right because you
approach him with your heart with an
intelligent flow of language that he
fully comprehends and prayer is dialogue
it's not monologue and anyway I didn't
understand those things but when I was a
Catholic I really tried I had religion
but I didn't have relationship they had
some of that mechanical repetitive oh
yeah Oh confession with painful the
worst thing about being a Catholic is
Saturday night all the bad stuff you've
done in the the poor priests it's got to
sit through that hundreds and hundreds
of times I don't know how they keep
sanity right to hear everybody's dirty
details and then to pronounce absolution
of course they believe that you have to
go through the priest to obtain your
absolution and you have to do penance
which usually involves like you said
repetitious prayer 10 our fathers 10
Hail Marys 10 glory bees and and then
you earn your forgiveness which to me is
an insult to the cross yes because if I
can be forgiven by saying a few prayers
repetitiously why Jesus have why Jesus
have to die and my salvation comes
through faith in the cross not faith in
my
our to repeat friends but anyway they
they taught what they thought was right
and they tried to help me and it was a
better environment than I could have
been in yeah in a lot of ways but it
left me empty and then I moved on to
Eastern religions after that
transitional point in my life where I
had a near-death experience but can we
go to the next picture I want to show
you something that's a picture of me
when I was 19 loved it that's when I
started searching yeah yeah yeah was a
rock musician and all that and then I
started studying under Yogi Bhajan
and Yogi Bhajan was his tall Sikh who
had a very imposing appearance about
himself very intense and he taught that
we could achieve God consciousness by
devoting ourselves to Kundalini Yoga
principles which I did very intensely
and for quite a few months I was
studying it and then I became a teacher
myself and I was running an ashram in
Tampa Florida where people lived
together to study on a more intense
level every day we started at 3:15 in
the morning first thing we did at 3:15
was taking a cold shower to wake up the
nervous system definitely that's one
thing that was true absolute weight said
you still do that today that way you
don't fall asleep while you're
meditating but anyway go to the next
frame if you would please yeah that was
a picture that was or an ink sketch that
was drawn by one of my students and that
was a student that studied under me at
University of South Florida and then if
you would the next one that's the
newspaper article that was the pivot of
my life the temperature beam newspaper
did this big half page article on me
that I thought would increase my class
attendance to way over a thousand right
at all these different colleges I was
teaching it instead it alerted this
local prayer group to start praying for
me on a continued
they cut that article out of the
newspaper and by the way I had to go and
find that on microfilm at the library in
Tampa that was quite an endeavor but
they cut that article out of the
newspaper and pinned it to their prayer
board and they had a 24-hour prayer
chain they assign somebody to be fasting
and praying over me every hour of every
day so I'm getting soaked with
intercession and strange things started
happening because God responds when we
start praying and I get this letter out
of the blue from an old friend of mine
in college who had left college for the
same reason I did
seeking after enlightenment well he told
me he walked in a church and heard an
audible voice say Jesus is the only way
and he said he was born again which was
a phrase I was unfamiliar with and I
initially thought he's just talking
about Christ consciousness or some of
the new-age things that we talked about
but his letter weighed on my mind
because he talked about the crucifixion
being essential to salvation and Jesus
bearing the sins of the human race and
that's the key to being cleansed from
sin and receiving him into your heart so
I knew the language was different but I
kind of pushed it aside at first and for
days it just kept weighing on my mind
until finally I thought I'm a truth
seeker so I don't want to just shove
something aside even though logically my
mind screams out against the idea of
Christianity being exclusively the only
way I thought I'm gonna open my heart to
it for one day and God was very gracious
to confine himself to my the parameters
of what I asked him to do but I said
Jesus I'm gonna dedicate this day to you
and if you are the only way to heaven
John 14:6 I am the way the truth and the
life no one comes to the Father but by
me Larry had quoted that in his letter I
said if that's true if you're the only
way to the Father and the only way to
eternal life then give me a sign today
and I was expecting a vision some type
of audible voice that's what Larry had
an audible voice or maybe some type of
supernatural happening
while I was meditating out-of-body
experiences something none of that
happen
that's how personally is yeah it was
what you need to convince you well he
knew I was too focused on supernatural
things yeah and he had orchestrate
things in such a way that it was clear
that it was God doing it but he was
using natural occurrences because anyway
that afternoon I was hitchhiking I had
to hitchhike everywhere because I've
made a commitment to own no material
things so I walked everywhere yeah if
you do that yes yeah if you do that you
have to use other people's material
things so I had to hitchhike so someone
who had a car could pick me up but
anyway I was headed for University of
South Florida one of the members of the
prayer group that had been praying over
me when they saw this newspaper article
was two miles away walking into a
laundromat and he heard the voice of the
Lord say get back in your van and start
driving that's all the instructions God
gave him get back in your van and start
driving he thought that's so strange God
doesn't want me to wash my dirty clothes
but he obeyed thank God yeah got in his
van tossed the clothes in back started
driving and whenever he felt an impulse
he turned and he drove two miles and saw
me hitchhiking he told me never picked
up hitchhikers cardinal rule yeah but
felt totally compelled and so he pulled
over I opened the door to his van and on
the ceiling of the van was a picture of
Jesus that he had taped there and I knew
this is my answer
this is it this is my sign so I'm
sitting on the edge of my seat waiting
for something and a few moments later he
said friend can I ask you a question I
said yes he said have you ever
experienced Jesus coming into your heart
I said no but when can i hey man you're
not supposed to give in that quick the
normal way he said you can come to our
meeting tonight us and man up and
praying since 3:30 this morning all I
did part of my agreement with the Lord
was I would not do any mantra yoga would
not meditate I would not read the
Bhagavad Gita of the Vedas all I did was
read the Bible
and pray to Jesus all day long and I
said I'm ready so we knelt down to the
back of the band and I gave my heart to
the Lord and it was so profound and real
when I knew Jesus came into my heart and
became my Savior and my lord that I went
to my yoga class that afternoon and and
I announced that I had become a
Christian
totally blew their minds that their guru
had become a Jesus Freak and so what
happened to the class did everybody just
like well no most of them were very
curious because I brought the guy with
me then it picked me a pitcher and
instantly another little divinely
orchestrated detail the guy who picked
me up was the only member of that prayer
group who was a former yoga student
himself so he understood my language so
God he was a student of Yogananda which
was a guru that I revered greatly and so
I was more prone to accept in the
authority of what he had to say so he
went with me to all my classes that week
and I told them that the classes were
disbanded I would no longer be teaching
yoga shut down my ashram everything I
knew I couldn't mix the two there's
people that say you can mix the two you
can't because Yoga is inextricably bound
to Hinduism and I knew that the
worldview are now embraced as a
Christian was not compatible with
Hinduism so what would you say to the
people because I hear this so often I'm
not doing yoga yoga like you say I'm
just doing the stretches well I have a
little booklet called seven reasons I no
longer practice yoga in fact yes right
there here we go at that book right here
hopefully you can see this book right
here this is good yeah that was number
two on Amazon by the way in comparative
religion a couple of weeks ago but it
would take me a whole hour or reduce to
a half hour to explain all seven reasons
but if no other reason is given if I go
to a yoga class in a yoga studio
I am putting a stamp of approval or
giving an endorsement to something that
is in extra perk
inextricably connected to a false
religion that is anti Christian or
unbiblical it is everywhere in sense
right and you go in there and there is a
contamination in the atmosphere and go
ahead I think that was the one thing
that Jessica really brought forth when
we asked this question with her and she
really said you know like the comparison
to the Ouija board you know the devil
cannot copyright spelling you know I
mean you can't just be like okay if
you're spelling than all that yeah yeah
or whatever the alphabet they're just
using the alphabet but when it's done in
that context with that board
that's good analogies then all of a
sudden you have allowed that it's like
you're saying yes yes I'm here on your
terms and you can let me in so so every
religion has these different components
to it and things that you do right and
you don't do them for no reason there's
meaning behind them so what is it that
yoga is the vehicle for what it what is
the purpose of yoga what is it well the
purpose you yoga you need our viewers
union with God's our union with God it's
it's the vehicle even if you're doing
the hatha yoga stretches yeah that's one
step on this journey toward Union
whatever like lifting your hands to God
in prayer but it's not to God and it's a
different pose or whatever and it's a
different concept of God and you're
opening yourself up to a spiritual world
when you do the meditation well let me
give you an example let me give you an
example I've had people come to me like
you said that said why do yoga but I
don't participate in the other stuff
when they chant ohm in the room I just
say Jesus right I said no wait a second
wait just a second that word ohm is from
well actually in the Hindu format or in
Sanskrit is stretched out into three
sounds
AUM instead of OM it's like a um and
each one of those sounds represents a
different deity like a
represents Brahma who is the creator god
and you represents Vishnu the preserver
got an M represent Shiva the destroyer
God and and so when you chant that once
again it's an invocation just like the
mudra is an invocation to Brahmin that's
with an in on the end the impersonal
oversoul when you chant ohm you're
invoking those three deities to come and
possess you and manifest out of you and
so if I'm in the room I don't care if
I'm a born-again Christian and I love
Jesus I'm surrounded with a swirl of
demonic activity that is dangerous here
on my is ground - people call me from
all over the world
desperate for prayer because they start
they were going to yoga classes and
started having Kundalini awakening
spontaneously and yeah and these energy
surges through their body that made them
feel deranged mentally etc well they're
coming under the influence of the same
spirit that dominates the atmosphere and
your own analogy then just just to make
this clear for our viewers what you're
saying is when you're when you're even
there let's say you're not even saying
the words yourself you're but you're
there you're in that presence it's like
going to a satanic ritual and being
present the only difference is I loved
God intensely when I was doing all that
sure I wasn't intentionally yeah in the
darkness I thought I was in the light
yeah I get it but I'm just saying what
would be the difference between being at
a satanic ritual and and false religious
you know with I'm not talking about
person's intentions right I'm just
saying essentially they're coming from
the same source right so as Christians
we would we would say I wouldn't be
found dead at a Christian an IRS satanic
ritual that that's completely wrong and
off-base but will be completely
comfortable with something else well can
you imagine Peter James and John going
to a yoga class and serenely
sitting there meditating on their higher
self while the rest of the room chats on
that or would they stand up and say hey
this is not going to get you to God
you're sincere you want truth but I know
the pathway his name is Jesus
only Jesus rose from the dead only Jesus
done on the cross for the sins of you
and that's the thing they're not so
there to evangelize they're there to
participate in some of it and they're
endorsing what's going on by being there
oh this must be suitable for Christians
I see three right over there Anna and so
what if they don't embrace the
philosophy they're not making a
statement against the philosophy and by
being there it seems like they're
supportive of the philosophy so I tell
people not to do it at all this the sad
thing is is many people to get caught up
in sort of a deception like this it's
like they truly want to embed or their
own lives they want to find a pathway to
God and it's like the devil's like
watching this going oh yeah look at
these seeking people over here so I'm
gonna hand them this so they're not
gonna be focused on this they're gonna
go over here and do this but I just I
love your testimony of how somebody
randomly sees a picture in a newspaper
posts it on the wall and prays about it
and all of a sudden you have this
miraculous transformation I mean
honestly it makes you a go the power of
prayer is powerful I mean we need to be
praying for people that are our teachers
and you don't I mean rather than like as
a Christian we look at this guy's a guru
he's exposed a video right isn't that
beautiful that literally were sitting
here next to a guru that would have been
leading many people into this thing but
because somebody saw the value in
praying for someone they don't even know
BAM when you come out of a certain
aspect of darkness you earn the right to
reach someone else that's bound by the
same thing because by the way there's a
guy that won me to the Lord by the way
those kids saw when it picks you up and
feedback yeah I want to ask I don't know
if you're gonna get too dense I could go
into how did you find out that this
group was praying for you and this guy
was gonna take you to his prayer group
well I went to the prayer group and they
prayed over me to they were like you're
the guy
I mean imagine imagine being that prayer
group and seeing that kind of in the
world he's here at our prayer group
praying when the answer comes they say
oh wow God answered did you believe that
yeah yeah yeah but I wanted to show you
this
that's an open-air gathering that I had
in Kumbakonam India and there's another
one in seven thousands of Hindus and
when I tell them that I was a guru and
that I embraced a religion but that I
found out Jesus was the only way Wow it
just breaks down the first year just
tell me your testimony yeah well I
preached to them I'm a minister
how many aspects I didn't know if this
was while you were still in no no no
that's after I became a Christian while
in the in the 1980s I started going to
India unfortunately India right now is
closed to open air meetings like this
Wow and I'm praying that it will open
back up again but you earned the right
in fact in fact I wrote a book because I
the Christian world I think is very
insensitive to being a communicator of
the gospel effectively to the culture in
the way the culture will receive it and
a number of years ago I tried to find
out a suitable book in a Christian
bookstore to give to a New Ager I was
talking to I couldn't find anything it's
all just so demeaning and insulting and
I thought there's no way I could give
that book I never make any I wouldn't
gain any ground wouldn't make any
positive influence on the person's life
so I wrote this book and searched the
true light but my initial purpose was
not to sell it but to give it away and
after I wrote it on mailed over 800
copies to every New Age leader and every
yoga teacher in Los Angeles County two
yoga studios shut down that's awesome I
offer this book the highest adventure
encountering God as a free download
off of my website the true light net hmm
the true light net and we've had I guess
people from about 50 countries or more
download this book we just recently got
it translated into Japanese and two yoga
teachers that are Japanese over in Japan
got saved and I will definitely have
links to this in the description sure
yeah free absolutely free for people and
share it with your friends that believe
in new-age they believe in Eastern
religions and yoga it's a very loving
presentation I believe in speaking the
truth in love and and I believe it will
convict someone of the truth you know
what's really way out is that one of the
things that helped turn me to
Christianity was a statement my guru
made yeah I can almost see fear in your
eyes
no one day when he was doing the Sun
saying teaching he said Jesus was an
avatar
now the word avatar means something
different now because the movie but
within the Hindu vernacular it means a
manifestation of God and most Indians
believe or many Hindus believe there
have been many manifestations of God so
he was one of many so to speak according
to the group he said but because Jesus
was an avatar he could only speak the
truth
hmm that kind of when I was in his
transitional period I started thinking
well if he could only speak the truth I
need to read the Bible right right what
do you say and I started seeing all
kinds of inconsistencies and
contradictions just to give a couple the
Guru I study down there taught that
Jesus death on the cross was just the
tragic death of a good man who went to
an extreme of suffering to fulfill his
purpose but it had no redeeming
qualities
no atoning quality about him yet at the
Last Supper I read where Jesus passed
the cup to all his disciples and said
this is the New Testament in my blood
which is shed for many for the remission
of sins he didn't say it was an example
of being passionate for purpose he's
for the remission of sins and I thought
if anybody knew what his death was about
it would sure be him because if he was
an avatar he had divine knowledge right
and so uh you only spoke the truth and
he said I am the way the truth and the
life and no man comes to the Father but
by me you have to accept it as truth
right well we had our way of explaining
you know what Jesus really meant was his
I am conscious his awareness of his own
infinitude or his own infinite nature
and when we develop now I don't believe
this now but I believed it back then
that when we develop the mindset that so
much so that we can boldly say I am that
I am that I have an eternal existence
eternal in the past and future then we
can come into this Christ consciousness
and that's really what he was talking
about no he wasn't saying that he was
talking about himself personally because
only Jesus rose from the dead that's
right
Buddha died at the age of 80 from food
poisoning they say traditionally and
he's still in the great war he's turned
to dust by man but Jesus died a much
more tragic death than that and yet he
came out of the grave three days later
and said I'm alive forevermore and and
and if you believe you'll rise from the
dead to he that believes on me though he
were dead yet shall he live and so
that's completely contrary to what I
taught as the yoga teacher I taught
reincarnation in Jesus says no its
resurrection mm-hmm and he taught one
life he didn't teach many lines yeah
right that's right so when I started
inspecting his teachings I immediately
recognized there was something unique
about Jesus mm-hmm what a story man well
I'm praise God that that you know
somebody saw value in praying for you
and now look at how many lives you have
been able to affect I mean going to
India into the heart of what they
believe is is bold but what a beautiful
thing what a beautiful testimony that
that God can now use you to spread their
real true light well if you if you come
out of a certain aspect of darkness
you earn a level of authority in
people's eyes because they then then
your words carry weight you're not just
an observer on the outside coming in
from a different philosophical worldview
you're somebody that actually walked
through it and decided this is wrong
there's a better way of doing it and
there's a right way of doing it and
absolutely Jesus is the way he is the
way he's the truth he's the life and all
another another issue that grew brought
up was that God is not personal
he's an impersonal it's an impersonal
force so he said God could not be so
personalized to overshadow a virgin and
plant a seed of life in her womb hmm and
yet the Bible teaches that Jesus was
born of a virgin him the Holy Spirit
overshadowed Mary so there you've got
that variance that contradiction not
enough the Quran even says it to see
historical sources yeah the Quran states
that the Spirit of God breathed into the
womb of Mary and and and he was formed
within her and in fact he's called the
Spirit of God in the Quran and so Wow so
even though Islam is not correct on a
lot of other issues they got that right
right and so praise God I'm glad I know
him and I'm glad I've got a way of
reaching other people hmm
and a message that will bring light
that's why I call my book in search of
the true light because I had a false
light before and it seemed to be light I
loved God but that's a huge difference
between loving God and knowing God sir
there's millions of Hindus who love God
there's millions of Muslims that love
God and there's millions of Buddhists
that may not have a concept of God but
they love the idea of truth and an
achieving a place of knowing the truth
and so there's a lot of genuine people
throughout the world and all they need
is Jesus now and what I would urge them
to do is just do what I did just say
Jesus if you're really the Savior come
to me reveal yourself to me prove your
reality Missa
and he said him who comes to me I will
not cast away he can you fly I mean I
have the same testimony growing up in
the Christian faith walking away from it
and I said God show yourself to me let
me see it and he revealed himself
mightily in my earlier years of my
conversion and so I know without a
shadow of doubt if you place that
decision in God's hands you say God I'm
gonna give you a day or whatever like
you said he's gonna show up mighty in
that one day I guarantee you if you give
him the opportunity and if you'll look
for the enemy exposes himself because I
never got to it and when we were talking
about it previously but the whole idea
of the Kundalini is supposed called
energy at the base of the spine coiled
in the form of a resting serpent that's
why the word Kundalini means serpent
power because through the breathing
exercises through the yoga physical
exercises the meditation and all the
other practices it's supposed to awaken
the Kundalini so that power travels up
through the chakras to your third-eye
are what they call the crown chakra
which is all mystical magical and untrue
but that's when you are launched into
God consciousness but it's called the
serpent enough biblical knowledge as a
Roman Catholic to know a serpent is a
symbol of something evil yeah but within
New Age spirituality the serpent
represents esoteric wisdom the serpent
is actually a good symbol that transfers
wisdom into your life which is a lot
which is like Gnosticism as well you
know that the serpent is a good thing
they were trying to enlighten the humans
that they had a spark of divinity inside
of them and stuff like that so we see a
lot of Gnosticism in films and things
right and there's a lot of apostasy in
Christianity now where people are
teaching and I've seen it I've seen it
among people that surprised me believed
in this that the kingdom of God is
within every
and being and and in order to find God
she just look within that's even being
popularized among some Christian circles
but that does away with the whole need
for the gospel Oh surprise you said a
presbyterian church invited you speak as
a guru yeah in the seventies right yeah
back in the 70 they didn't realize that
they were allowing a completely non
Christian worldview into their mist and
that was my biggest class I had about a
hundred and fifty students at the
Presbyterian University so see the dent
was clever he's gonna use something like
oh it's just exercise it's just this
like little thing and like a snake he's
gonna get in there and he's gonna wreak
havoc but he comes in through this this
ulterior motive like you're searching
for light I'm gonna give you some light
but it's really I uses all the same
terms yes and you know that's one of the
things that's confusing you know that
light yeah or love all right ever is
right yeah light light lights a good
thing I'm not white truth yeah truth
yeah of course
yeah use all those those buzzwords and
they just redefines them Wow and some of
the gurus are masters at using language
that sounds very Christian in order for
the two cultures to mesh Yogananda was a
master at that and I don't mean that in
a complimentary way he was a master at
making the yoga approach seem completely
compatible with Christianity and that's
that's the one thing I said before we
started recording this that the big beef
of most New Agers which is a crazy way
of saying it because many of them are
vegetarians but the big beef of New
Agers is that all religions are one all
religions are have common elements and
that's true but when I started writing
my book in search of the true light I
thought well I'm going to I'm going to
explore I'm going to examine all the
different religions and I'm going to
find the areas of commonality and the
one thing that I discovered is that
almost every area of similarity is at
the base of religion where you cultivate
a good Christian term would be
christ-like attributes in your life
forgiveness humility meekness gentleness
you're reaching for character
development you find the golden rule in
every major religion in fact I could I
could I've got a whole list of the
Golden Rule in about 12 different
religions in the book and and so that
makes people think well then all of
these religions must be saying the same
thing when it comes to love yes when it
comes to forgiveness yeah a Course in
Miracles which is completely new age
talks a lot about forgiveness but it
bends it to a non-biblical extent yeah
but when you get beyond that base of
religion into things that are higher
theologically like the nature of God or
the nature of salvation or the nature of
the universe in its relationship with
God different religions take completely
different roads of interpretation and
they're no longer compatible and that's
that's why people think that all
religions are one but they're not yeah
because either I have a soul that can
live on eternally as Hinduism teaches as
Christianity teaches as islam teaches or
i cease to exist as a as a human being
and i have no soul as buddhism teaches
but those two ideas cannot be compatible
at all and what i when i preached in
india one analogy I almost always bring
out is comparing what Copernicus taught
to what Ptolemy taught Ptolemy was a
second century astronomer that taught
that the earth was the center of the
solar system and the Sun revolved around
the earth over a thousand years later
Copernicus comes along and says no it's
heliocentric the Sun is at the center
and the Earth revolves around the Sun
now if they were contemporaries and
could discuss their views isn't even
remotely possible or logical that
Copernicus could say hey Ptolemy you can
have your truth than I can in my truth
we'd both be right well of course not
one is right at the expense of the other
being wrong and when you get to all
these religions we've mentioned today
then what has got to be right at the
expense of the others being wrong and I
contend that Christianity is the path
that works well thank you so much for
sharing your testimony with us we
actually have his book here
he has generously given us some copies
of this so if you want a copy of this
book you got to send us your email and
we will send this to you for free while
supplies last
the link will be in the description
below but if not you can check out
Mike's website we'll have that in the
description below as well and Mike
thanks so much for sharing this with
your testimony and I'm excited we're
gonna we're gonna cover another topic
right after this one so if you guys want
to hear more from Mike stay tuned next
week we'll have the next show god bless
[Music]